blake
shields of brahmitz how's it going man
thanks for having me thanks for coming
on the program
happy to do it i'm super pumped for the
convo
grateful to michael holt for introducing
us yeah
michael holt the dangerous the saintly
yeah the savage and the scene
exactly i know yeah he's an amazing
person
he is and he was also episode 700
which was so beautiful yeah we talked
so much about spirituality and
well-being and masculinity it was just
oh nice also your audience is familiar
with him
yeah i thought i would have to make a
make an introduction for
people who don't know who we're talking
about
he's a meditator extraordinaire but even
before he started meditating he's been
like a
lethal weapon proficient in yes
like three different martial arts and
yes
but he's he's civilized himself whereas
he used to be kind of a
you know kind of a little and he'll say
this himself i'm not talking [ __ ]
a wild man he was a you know he he was a
uh you know he he liked to fight
and so now what he teaches is sort of
this this civilizing process of
you know being a savage who in some
sense
wants to fight who's in touch with that
primal part of himself but at the same
time
holds it at bay um yeah there's this
beautiful balance
exactly yeah there's the wisdom that
balances exactly
yeah and then also both of you
have been profoundly influenced by
george haas
yeah and that's been interesting and
we're excited to have
him on the show soon yeah that's so cool
in l.a we're pumped for that
and we'll unpack a lot of
the the art the acting
the spirituality of your
journey and i'm super excited for that
so and also for those that are
interested
in diving deeper
in blake has been
teaching yoga and meditation he's acted
in dozens of principal roles
sponged up the planetary mystic
traditions and is producing the arsonist
of venice a full-length dramatic play
about a brilliant novelist who is
planning a murder and you can find
all of his links in the bio below to
veniceyogi.com
also his imdb page his instagram his
wikipedia page you can go and
look him up in greater detail and follow
him
blake let's start things off with
the macro
level chronology you were teaching me
a bit about the journey of having
sort of the counter culture style
parents that
were seeking the perfect geographic
location and you had three other
siblings
and you were from new york new jersey to
israel to boise and then to this
la acting spirituality art vibe so
what take us through that story yeah
so um i was born in uh new york state
and and like like you just mentioned my
parents were
um pretty wild characters i mean these
are uh
children of the 60s in the truest sense
they were um
what did i call them rebel outlaws uh
truly i mean really uh in in
ways that are both fun and interesting
and also quite
harrowing which you know we can get into
but it's
it's um it's meaningful to me to
understand
myself and the way i turned out in the
context
this larger context that's not only to
do with
them as individual human beings but
the whole cultural explosion of the 60s
and all of the forces that were
coming together or colliding at that
moment so that's definitely in my
cells and so
when i was born they were living on a
farm you know they decided to clean up
their act
and move to a farm and we're running a
50-head
uh dairy farm in in upstate new york and
that's that's where that's what was
going on when i was born
i think they thought it was going to be
like a like an early disney film
but it turned out that it was back
breaking
and just you know soul-destroying
work year after year so my brother and i
were born there on the farm
they lost the farm when i was two
and drove down to new jersey with
literally
nothing just the clothes on their back i
think my dad said he had a hundred
dollars
and um some stuff in the car whatever
could fit in the
hatchback or whatever it was and then
um this is what they would do they would
just drive into a town and say oh this
looks nice
and then just move there just stay there
so this was a
a town called cape may in new jersey
which is a resort town
and they just got jobs as waiters
um waiter and waitress and my
sister was born there and then
the they decided they didn't like it
because it emptied out
except in the summer they drove there in
the summer
so it must have been the summer of 79
and my sister would have been born
that september by which point
uh the place had just emptied out
and so they said all right well let's
get out of here and then
my mother's family lived in california
so she thought well let's move
closer to my family but not too close
yeah because they're
you know they had their whole set of
problems going on there
so we moved to santa cruz or just
outside santa cruz tiny town
boulder creek redwood town
seven redwoods in the yard yeah so
big chunk of my childhood there three
years
and beautiful memories there
well i come from
from well trauma
of violence in my family there was not a
a pretty upbringing um you know that's
i sort of alluded to the the dark side
of that
60s thing you know my
there was uh you know there were
it was a rocky childhood so as
interesting and
fun as it was and as fascinating as my
parents were there's this
other aspect which i feel like i would
be remiss not to
touch on because it bears on my whole
spiritual journey and on the kind of art
i make
and stuff like that so in a sense it's
kind of the balance or the synthesis
between the hyperliberal with a slight
conservative in a sense you want to
take the best of both
yeah and if you're hyper in either
direction by itself
that can be extreme yeah that's what i'm
trying to get at yeah yeah
and i think you know both of my parents
had
difficult childhoods themselves and they
had um
they when you combine that
with the kind of cultural
explosion implosion that they underwent
each in their own ways that they were a
part of these
major um culture wars and
breakages in the culture in the 60s i
think that's a very
potent set of um
traumas and losses for them which
played out of course in my childhood in
a big way
so anyway that's in itself such a
fascinating part of the
united states history and
the way that it affected like your
parents that then ended up passing along
to you
in a sense the
denuclearization of the family unit to
this sort of
hyper openness of the
psychedelic and theogenic phenomena that
was emerging
is both extremely beautiful and at the
same time it can make it
so that potentially that slight bit
of conservatism gets completely blown
away so the
traditions are completely lost as well
or like the wisdoms from even like the
founding fathers at the constitutional
days the declaration of independence
days
can be completely lost so if that's the
balance of those two
in one that is
the optimal sort of sorting algorithm
if you will where you drain the dirty
bath water from like the left
and the right but you take the beautiful
baby out of both sides and then merge it
together into one
yeah and that was such a hard thing to
do at that time because in the 60s
i mean you know it's like what's good
about
about jim crow what's good about
uh deep
structural you know ambient racism
and my mother was truly a hero she was
on the front lines of
this civil rights act in the early 60s
before the
voting rights act and she you know
she marched with a student non-violent
coordinating committee and
um congress on racial equality i mean
she was there yeah and wow
so but she took it seriously
she believed in the principles of
equality
and uh tolerance and we're all one
people
humanity is not you know not two
it's one yeah and so she fell in love
with a
a black activist and brought him home
to her wealthy uh
wasp parents in la canada and it did not
go over well
yeah and just explain what the acronym
means white anglo-saxon
protestant yeah um
it's kind of a it has a kind of ironic
um
yeah tinge to it whenever you uh
whenever you say wasp i could be you
know because i think
there's so much privilege that um that
is associated with
that group um but
how'd that go for her it was uh you know
a devastating event
for her family for her um they
they um i think the
the memorable quote was get
that n-word out of this house
jeez and she refused to stop seeing him
and they
they had him they had her involuntarily
uh committed to a mental institution
uh tricked her into flying out to
connecticut
and then wow and so
you know if you can imagine the the you
know
the level of wounding that that would
um do to a person yeah
and you know getting passed on in
familial lineage yeah
yeah so this is what i mean by like
transgenerational
trauma that is a function not just of
family dynamics
but of cultural forces at a scale that's
even it's hard to even
comprehend it it's so big
you know so slavery was
totally fine until uh
1830s i think was the first time anyone
ever
came up with the serious idea of banning
it making it illegal everybody thought
it was
fine until then i think the abolition
movement started in
the netherlands and in england
maybe 50 years before that but before
that it never occurred to anybody that
this was a problem
and so this is only 18
30s england bans slavery across
its empire it's only 130 years
later still the
the um the repercussions
are reverberating as they still are uh
yeah that my mom gets hit with this
you know no kidding so it's this this
meaning making to try to see
greater and greater context to
understand how i ended up
the way i did i find very helpful
yeah yeah so that aspect of the
familial lineage transgenerationally now
through you has been
massive and in a sense one of the key
roles of
the most youthful generation is to
stop the trauma in the familial lineage
and even
science is proving that with epigenetics
these
these dna methylation and histone tails
where you can
literally create a stoppage of the
perpetuation
of things like cortisol hormone
stressing
or freaking out with anger
because as we're going to talk about in
spirituality we
master the ability to
of
to dump water in a sense on the
flame roots of the monkey mine that is
always moving towards craving or
aversion
or is reacting right away but rather we
create that pause
that gap that's what sort of enables us
to be at
peace or in a state of happiness that
then we can more equanimously
more meditatively more wisely and
gracefully engage
and so that's sort of what the youthful
consciousness does
in these ways so what then
transpires because i know there's you
know the migration to
israel yeah so at a certain point
we were living in california and my
mother
had decided that she was
going to become jewish like my dad
i think they thought that would be good
for the marriage and my mother was
really interested in religions i think
she was pretty much
every religion that you can think of at
some point during my upbringing and
literally i mean she she was a
practicing
again christian then she was jewish then
she was
universalist unitarian then she was
baha'i then she was
although i might have gotten those
backwards and then she was
um hare krishna etc so i was
she was even in a new age cult for a
while yeah so
anyway she um
decided that she wanted to be jewish
and so we started being like a
practicing jewish family
at home and then eventually she put a
picture of jerusalem on the fridge and
decided
that this would be the next thing we
were talking about the geographical cure
how a certain kind of person thinks that
happiness fulfillment freedom is right
over the yep
right around the next bend in the
highway and for her
and then she got my dad on board that
was jerusalem
to raise their kids in the holy land and
so they
look they flew four kids out to
jerusalem and we
we lived there for five years
um which so from the time i was seven
until i was 12
we were in israel and of course a lot of
amazing
experiences and friends there
and then we came back because my
parents didn't want us to serve in the
military because of
what was going on there politically it
was it was
already pretty ugly yeah in 89
so we moved back why boise idaho
um
so my dad was playing the piano
in the lounge of the king george hotel
in downtown jerusalem so cool
yeah and that was his gig and he would
ask people that came in once they
decided to
to move away the system his version of
google
of checking out the world in 1989
was to ask people that came to the hotel
where they were from and what it was
like there exactly
and yeah exactly and we can still do
that today
in 2021 and beyond when we just simply
sit down in a ride share
to just ask the person that's driving
the vehicle about their life story
yeah totally it's a google i like how
you said that that's what you're dead
yeah so it was it was uh
you know and you'd get a lot of
information that way um
and my dad's charming and personable so
excuse me he would get people talking
and
they wanted to go someplace that was
english speaking they wanted to go
someplace
that had natural beauty so those were
the criteria they couldn't get into new
zealand because
of the immigration laws my dad was
already too old or something
so it was down to england or the states
but they didn't want to do england
because it's
so expensive in london and they didn't
want to live in the sticks so anyway
so it got whittled down to um
the states and these people would come
into the hotel and say
well you know he'd say so what's it like
in phoenix
right yeah then that it'd be like hot
yeah exactly well that's actually funny
that you say that because
my dad said this guy this sort of like
big tough like phoenix guy went on for
20 minutes without pausing about how
wonderful
phoenix was and how great it was
everything was great about it and then
when he finally left her a moment to
interject his wife said
it's too hot harry yeah
perfect exactly yeah i mean let's get
like 110 degrees there in the middle of
the night
so so they found uh
boise and portland and seattle i think
those were the cities they whittled it
down to and then which
aligned more with the spiritual i think
yeah
yeah yeah and so
eventually boise idaho
yeah um the guy who told my dad about
boise in jerusalem
was a kind of cowboy a rancher from
boise and he said
boise's a beautiful city but
there's a lot of simple people there my
dad didn't know what he meant
yeah we moved to boise and we
yeah we found out what simple people
were
basically it's just you know it's not a
polite term but that was his way of
saying
yeah redneck basically in a sense yeah
yeah
country folk more more portland and
seattle on the spiritual
yeah yeah yeah yeah boise has
a tinge of like montana
and wyoming wyoming and yeah and then
yeah you're from dakota right yeah
yeah exactly so the dakotas and nebraska
and
kansas and you know yeah exactly
yeah yeah so okay so then that was
six years in boise so i spent junior
high
in high school in boise i went to boise
high i got into acting there and
cool that's where i developed my
interest in
all this kind of spiritual stuff that's
ultimately turned into a real
path for me and um
but i came out to la after high school
to knowing that you wanted to pursue
this acting and art
um yeah and at the very least i was
going to go to school for it
exactly and what is it the three-year it
was at the california
or the american academy of germanic arts
the american academy of dramatic arts
yeah it was in pasadena when i went but
now it's
it's in hollywood on la brea okay and
that is that
also acronymed as aada yeah yeah
yeah but by the time i got to
the academy i was i was
really a mess um i was
i had a really difficult time in high
school i was
really depressed and i was dropping
acid about once a month for about two
years
wow during high school once a month
for two years yeah i think i did about
20 times
over the course of my junior and senior
year wow
and it pretty much bottomed me i mean i
i was uh what they call a permafry case
at 17 where i just basically never
recovered from
this last acid trip that i had
and it took years were you doing that
because there was the
depression and the escapism is that what
or was it
also a kind of a
calling towards understanding the nature
of reality at a deeper level than
physicalism
i mean i think i wanted to
um i think there there was there was a
kind of more than just
escapism going on i think i was trying
to explore
consciousness and i think that i sensed
that there was
an avenue for healing and psychological
cool integration possible through these
substances but it was all just groping
and flailing in the dark i had no tools
no guidance no context no conceptual
framework for what i was doing
and it was extremely dangerous and i i
paid a heavy price for it
but also it really did plant the seed
for
um for the future for my meditation
practice which
that's pretty cool maybe about 15 years
later became
quite serious what what does permafry
mean in the yeah yeah like permanently
fried
but how but how if it's permanently
fried
how would there even be the
interest in atta and you know going to
california
you know what i mean permafry seems like
oh that's it
like this is like couch potato or
something right yeah
yeah i mean i was um
i after about two months after that
particular experience which was
very very profound very beautiful
but also really really jarring
and shattering i was able to
function
reasonably well i could go to school
i could complete assignments but there
was about two months there where i
couldn't do anything like that as in
were you going to school were you
staying at home i dropped out of high
school
at that point wow and then i eventually
went back
to uh the alternative school
wow sort of the uh you know like
basically like a special needs school
and i mean i'm you know i'm like smart
person well-read you know i but that's
where i landed because i was so
you know um so were any of your other
siblings
sing around with lsd or no
it was just you on the anthogens yeah
that's so interesting
wow yeah i wouldn't recommend
the combination of a traumatic
attachment history uh
unprocessed unresolved childhood trauma
and unguided
unsupervised psychedelic
experimentation at that age that's not a
good
recipe yeah there are entheogens
done with wisdom and there are antiogens
done
which in a sense provided
the treasure on the other side of the
trauma which was the
like you described sort of the
frameworks and protocols that enabled
this
depth of spiritual practice that exists
today
yeah eventually i came back to
that territory but in a much more
integrative sustainable way yeah
through meditation and yoga and therapy
and
yeah exactly yeah so
when you moved out here you had done
enough acting
in high school where you knew that this
was something that you wanted to pursue
this
three years at ada and then
you're picking up all these tips
tricks techniques that enhance your
ability to basically get
noticed by the casting and
for them to even for your
in a sense your agents and your managers
to
really like you and to feel like you
have the ability to be somebody that
they want to take on as a client
yeah yeah it was uh i mean i got i was
really lucky
and it was just i was just sort of a
charmed
story at that point i the
um the american academy put on a
showcase
for us uh third year students where they
they literally did the work for us
of inviting industry so casting
directors directors
agents producers managers to the show
and i did my scene and i got
i got calls you know i had like three
people call me and wanted to
talk about representing me i mean it was
like i don't think it's that easy these
days
um i got i was lucky
and so i got an agent straight out of
school
and started auditioning pretty much
right away and
and um i was working within
less than a year uh which is also
unusual
and uh so i had a whole
career in hollywood i mean it's still
ongoing but it's
certainly you know i had a 10-year
period where i was working a lot and i
was on the
you know i was on that very short list
of actors that were
getting called in for you know high
high level tv stuff um
i haven't given up but uh you know my
booking
um is you know it's
my booking rate has not been uh the same
for a few years but
we're you know we're still plugging away
you know
hollywood has a way of um
you know ups and downs they told me when
i was a kid and i was like
not for me it's gonna be a straight shot
all the way to the you know
to the top of the mountain and never
look back
but that's not how it worked out but
when i stopped working as much as i
had been about
nine years ago
i refocused energy into
meditation and yoga in a bigger way and
so in a way it was
in a way it was good it was good that
things changed in that respect uh it
it created a space for me to pursue
other
things more seriously
and now i'm i'm writing a lot i'm
writing plays
and producing them with friends and
um that feels extremely
meaningful um that's really where
art and spirituality intersect i think
in what i'm writing not that i'm writing
about
you know spirituality i'm not but i'm
writing about the human heart
the best i know how and trying to
illuminate it
especially in respect to trauma and
loss which is i think what meditation
does
uh it illuminates the dark um
that's what for for me that's the the
overlap
the venn diagram of art and spiritual
practice
um they're both trying to illuminate
the spaces in our minds and hearts that
um often prefer to
avoid yeah
that's a beautiful understanding of
the peak capacity for
both art and spirituality is to
heal and also to
pierce the veilless veil in
understanding our true nature
and
the what we were just looking at here
which is the television and film
sort of record is crazy there's been
like a
big big history
and like you said over time it's ups and
downs and it's
you know you have a lot of different
unique
roles that you take on across these
projects
but that the the role is
in itself you would say you do
specifically drama
you versus comedy um yeah yeah that's
what i've tended to do
i mean i i i like a certain kind of
comedy
um that's odd and
off the beaten track and i like you know
indie comedy type vibe i
i i'm good at and i i my personality
lends itself
well to that but i yeah i can't really
do
i mean i can i shouldn't say i can't but
i i don't
like sitcom type yeah stuff
i i i like watching it sometimes but
it's just not the kind of instrument
that i have
exactly it's not the instrument of the
unit it's not the expression of the unit
it's more on the drama yeah um and i
tend to play really dark characters
yeah correct yes so um
yet at the same time the spiritual
practice has been anchoring
light in throughout so maybe walk us
through kind of
how the spiritual practice evolved
simultaneously as the art in acting
yeah that's really interesting um
um i started working quite a bit
and after my big acid experience my
senior year in high school i didn't
touch
drugs or alcohol for at all
for eight years yep and
so that was a i guess a slow process of
incubation and healing for me that
period
slow i mean i was shell-shocked
you know coming out of that childhood uh
in that drug history uh i barely
limped out into the world yeah barely
limped out of school yeah
yeah and so so that's why the abstinence
for eight years yeah yeah yeah it wasn't
necessary
totally totally and then when i was
about 25
three things happened all at once i
started working
a lot and making a lot more money
i decided to get really into yoga
and started taking classes and doing
trainings and
i started partying so all three of those
things happened at once
at once yeah it was just yeah so it was
a real kind of a time of like
opening an expansion for me um
and i you know from the time i was 25
26 i got more and more into yoga and
more and more and more into
meditation and at the same time
i was partying and spending all the
money i was making
yeah uh and so it was it's hard to
understand even for me
exactly how i was able to do all of
those things
um because i was i was working more and
more
um but eventually i decided that
yoga and meditation were probably a
better bet
than partying which was
somewhat like exploring consciousness
but also eventually it just became
like pure hedonism um and also
it got pretty dark at times um as
tends to happen with certain kinds of
drugs
um but when i i remember
when i was 30
33 or 34 i had done a few
vipassana retreats three or so
and i remember thinking
i just i want to go to bed on time so
that i can wake up in the morning and
meditate
hmm that's what i care about interesting
and so
i was just so passionate about the
meditation i was so interested in it
and it had been a lifelong interest
since i was a teenager
i just decided to forego the
the party and for a long time i was
i mean really rigorous really
disciplined
on and off retreat for a long time and
i'm still
on this journey but i don't know i think
maybe my practice isn't a
mellower phase but yeah yeah but anyway
um
so 28 total vipassana meditation
retreats which is
nuts yeah anywhere ranging from a week
to
30 days yeah yeah a week to a month i
did one month long
in february of 2016. wow
yeah that's really getting out those
roots
yeah that was um
that was a very deep experience there's
all of a sudden
blake shields has disappeared
yeah i mean literally in a sense yeah
blown out nirvana yeah i mean
i
yeah i was really grateful for my
teachers
they gave me a way to unpack
and interpret my experiences in
meditation
[Music]
you know in a manner that felt grounded
um that felt yes um tethered
to the earth at the same time as it was
in that quote blown out it's also
tethered to the earth
which is the perfect balance yeah yeah
so i'm grateful to george
haas for that and shinzon young and also
my my yoga teacher and friend julian
walker
who you should have him on this show
sometime he is fascinating
yeah any recommendation from you we
would have to have on
julian walker yeah all right fascinating
invitational intellectual
yeah and practitioner local by chance
yeah oh perfect
oh perfect yeah yeah okay great i'll
note that and we'll
we'll talk about afterwards cool okay um
but i feel like i sort of went off on a
tangent you were asking specifically
about the hollywood
trajectory yeah so from 25 to
30 early 30s was the
partying was happening simultaneously as
a spirituality
and then it faded away as you became
more and more spiritually realized and
you wanted to prioritize the meditation
yeah
yeah okay cool cool yeah i just realized
that
yeah this was a better bet
yeah a more sustainable journey
yeah and was going to heal
a lot of the transgenerational
trauma as well as yeah well that that
was the hope
and still is i think i've i've managed
to unwind a lot of that
um but it's through meditation and
and therapy and
and friendships totally yeah
and becoming more of a ninja in general
spirituality gives you that ninja
jedi ability like we were saying with
that pause or that gap
or to just see these sort of levels of
consciousness where people are
this contracted egoic energy
that's separate that's finite biological
versus those that recognize themselves
as this eternal buddha this awakened one
that is just butterfly effecting out
like sahaja samadhi
this meditative consciousness in their
daily activities
and you can just feel that resonance and
it's so juicy and peaceful and happy
totally and i like to say in my
meditation
classes and especially at the end of my
yoga classes in
in shavasana i say so
may this practice bring you joy and
vitality and peace but so much more than
that
and maybe far more importantly
may it radiate out spill
shine out from you and into the world
to light up the network around you
so that everyone you meet and everyone
they meet
is illuminated by it this is not
just yeah that's perfect
that's the bodhisattva path yes that's
what
that whole thing is about that we're
practicing not only
for ourselves but but for everyone that
we care about and
and for the extended network which which
extends far beyond what we can
probably imagine and so exactly it
matters what we do
exactly union yoga
hypnosis or mysticism
is union with what it's union with god
or the absolute
and as you do that
practice of rather than like in the
parable of the prodigal son where you
seek externally for happiness
in the maya in the illusion in the dream
rather you turn inward because that
intoxication
is not going to
be the happiness or the peace that is
eternal
you turn inward and you recognize the
diamond necklace of consciousness of
awareness that is already around your
neck
as rumi said that is refracting the
unique source light
it's an eternal source light in these
dreams
and that diamond around your neck is
your unique expression like we were
saying with this childlike analogy of
the
eye the pupil is the shared
observer the shared witness among all of
us
and the iris just like here you have
this different beautiful colored iris
than this unit does and that is our
unique
expression and that is so
beautiful to be able to recognize
that turn inward because that turn
inward is like you described it's the
tantric path simultaneously where you
weave your realizations into
the social fabric you no longer see
atlas and blake as these two separate
biological finite units
but rather you see blake as
the same god observer
as you in its own unique creative
expression so you would never
hurt your own body your own being
and so that's where it really helps out
into the welfare of all that buddhahood
totally yeah yeah i think what you're
pointing to is very real i think we
probably might language it differently
but i mean yeah the way i would let's
hear how you language it i would love to
hear that
i would say that
there are certain states that you can
access
through meditation or that just occur
spontaneously and certainly um with
psychedelics
they tend to occur or mdma or something
like that
um and certainly in meditation where
the boundary between interior
and exterior self and other that the
seeming boundary
apparently collapses yeah and so that
there's no sense of separation between
self and other that that you and i are
happening in the same field of awareness
yes and that insight
or that angle on reality
is extremely liberating
it and it does like as you say foster
empathy and compassion yes uh i think
that's
i think that's true um uh
and the other piece that you touched on
about realizing that
lasting fulfillment does not exist
in any external thing that you might
get uh now that or or imbibe
yeah yeah that is um a
very very difficult pill to swallow
yes so i mean i'm still working on that
especially when the cultural drum
is going consume consume
consume happiness is external
and it's just drumming that in the
educational
infrastructure itself yeah and so you
have this ignorant parenting that's
propagating
the curriculum of maya to
the children and so from birth
you're getting the egoic onion layers
that
form versus if you look at like the kogi
shamans the that are the
the mamas themselves and many other
indigenous
birth trajectories the onion layers of
the egoic separate identity never
form in the first place and that's one
of the goals of conscious parenting
is to have the child evolve in that way
so there's never
this egoic formation that even happens
in the first place
yeah i think we we may have stumbled on
our first
philosophical disagreement perfect let's
do it i love these
i love these let's do it i'd love to
hear your your perspective on it um
i think that
well here's how i would approach it i
think that in the west
in what we think of as modernity or the
developed world
there is this new invention
relatively new compared to history right
of human history
called the individual right the
individual human being
is like this is a new idea it's a new
concept it really got
developed in in the enlightenment and
that the individual human being is the
locus
of rights responsibilities creativity
and
[Music]
and experience
so i think that was a good development
i would never trade it but what i would
say and this kind of goes to your point
is that when it goes wrong with the
the pathological side of this emphasis
on the individual
yeah we get the kinds of things that
you're talking about
you know unbearable separation
psychopathy exaggerated agency
yes yes um so it's the balance of the
individual with the collective that we
would
never want to trade it i mean if you
grow balance it's the balance
it's a balance because you do it's it's
always the simultaneity this is the
massive learning it's always the
simultaneity
of that sort of non-dual
there is nothing to seek with the
dualistic concession of there is a veil
this veil to pierce and to
undergo this union with god or the
absolute
and so in the individual versus
collective
it's to again this analogy of where you
drain the dirty bath water
from reach and then you uplift the
crystal clear baby and then merge them
yeah exactly it's the ken wilbur thing
to transcend
and include what the what was
good about the previous stage which in
this case was
community family cohesiveness
connection song ritual etc like nothing
wrong with any of that we don't want to
get rid of it
but then we added this idea yes the
individual human being
gets to be original and unique and
self-expressive
exactly um that's the unique that's the
source light that refracts through the
uniqueness of the diamond
rather than the sameness that's
that's what to say but that is a western
uh innovation
it's very much like last 500 years
yeah have been promulgating that and
it's
and again that's where we do the
draining of the dirty bath water yet
uplifting the clean baby from both the
collective and the individual and
merging that into one
yeah because we each have the diamond or
the jewel
around our necks and yet the
uniqueness of the diamond slash the
jewel
is the creative expression of the
individual
and it's so beautiful yeah yeah and it
can get
really off track right yeah like if you
think that you're only an individual
and they're not also a member of the
human commons
yes and also i'm a member of various
groups a family a
a neighborhood a a gym a book club a
nation
etc then that you have rights and
responsibilities within each of those
contexts
and that you're none of those things
that you're a radically centerless
field of awareness roomy
right simultaneously i am
what does he say i am
this he says
first last inner
outer only this breath breathing
human being yeah uh
beyond all of those small identities we
are
this radical yep centerless field
and so if we can if we can keep all of
those in mind exactly simultaneously
yeah
individual i am a human being i'm my own
person
i'm blake there's no one else like me i
have my own dreams
and aspirations and biography and
needs and so on
and my own unique creativity and
i'm identical in a sense to every other
human being
like we share the same firmware exactly
and
there's a there's a brotherhood and
sisterhood there yes
and i'm a member yes of all these
different groups
i mean racially religiously nationally
and
so on and so forth planetarily and i'm
none of those things
yep if we can remember those four things
yeah we're pretty good
yeah we're not going to get too off
track exactly and that's sort of
what we were saying earlier it's good
that we made this clarity is that
it's not so much about the
curricula of conscious parenting
being around solely the
god realization it's also around the
creative entrepreneurial actualization
at the same time i love that yeah yeah
that's so important
so important perfect i think that's
absolutely critical because
when yeah when teachers teach all the
meditation stuff and the going in
and the interior illumination stuff and
failed to mention
that oh yeah by the way you also have to
figure out what you're going to do
in your life yes how you're going to
make a living how you're going to
um unfold your self into
the world in a meaningful way perfect
that's a real problem
perfect and i love what jordan peterson
i was just thinking that
he and tony robbins and gary vaynerchuk
those kind of guys yeah
yeah i mean peterson's even more complex
but
i i haven't read a ton of tony robbins
but he said he said you don't unfold
your i'm paraphrasing your creative
expression what you have to give if you
don't give what you have to give to the
world
then there will be there will forever be
a hole
in the fabric of the universe in the
exact shape of your soul
i thought that was beautiful yeah the
world needs us
and that's funny in the simultaneity
it's both the non-dual tradition will
say that
that exact phenomenon never happens
while the dualistic concession will say
that that phenomena does happen so
within this indra's
net of these interconnected
and inter-reflective jewels or diamonds
that are around each of our necks
it is both simultaneously impossible
for you to not actualize while it's also
possible in the dualistic concession for
you to
not actualize and that's sort of the
interesting simultaneity
of the non-dual
with the dual at the same time because
that's why within the dualistic
concession
when you look at all the
self-actualization literature
that that is what is pointing towards
the
optimization and the efficiencies of the
creative manifestation of the unique
jewel to express itself in the dream
is which is the being able to recognize
all
is what does that did it follow your
thought
oh it follows on your thought that you
said a bit ago which is that
we are all of the layers exactly so
we're the layer
of the finite biological creature
which is the most sort of concession
and then the next layer up is something
like the
dualistic concession that the
finite biological creature has something
to seek
it has something to find it has
something to enlighten
itself with and then it find finds that
diamond necklace of consciousness of
awareness that was already around its
neck
and it recognizes this is the god
realized state when it recognizes the
source
light that refracts through its unique
jewel or diamond that then it
expresses itself in a way that is more
realized to the true nature of existence
and then there's one more
sort of layer beyond that which is the
both it's beyond
samsara and nirvana it's beyond the
cycle
of birth and death and beyond being
blown out
and it's beyond the dream the creation
designs it's beyond all that
is it is the absolute the ineffable
which
even rejects the observer it rejects
even the god consciousness state and
so there's all of the simultaneity
across these layers
and that being the truth yet
that being the ultimate truth yet we
have to recognize that the spiritual
truth is the forever truth yet the
empirical truth is the truth for
now in the creation design that this one
is
so that's something that we've been sort
of playing with
yeah yeah wow there's a lot there
um yeah i have some things i could say
about that
also curious where you want to go next
and i think i have to take a quick
break is that can you hold it down for
just restroom stuff yeah
okay yeah i will hold it down yeah
exactly i will hold it down
totally i'll hold down the fort yeah
right i love it
i love it so we are now entering into a
brief
monologue based on what we've been
talking about
with blake
i really appreciate where blake and i
have gotten with
simultaneity that
by far seems to be the key
true simultaneity across all of these
layers
is what is ultimate truth
to truly at an embodied level
recognize that simultaneity across the
layers
is what
is at the most truest
that's it
so true simultaneity
is most true across
all of those layers
at the same time
if you can see the rings
that are ever
expanding
and relaxing into that
you will see the finite physical
biological creature
that then goes outward one ring
into the mind perfect timing
come on back on
yeah i'm really glad that we had the
restroom break that was solid because
now
it's going to enable the smoothness you
know it's a very important
uh aspect of the physicalism side of
things yeah exactly
so we were we were sharing how basically
the true
simultaneity that we've gotten to
is the essence of what is the ultimate
truth so in a sense it's the ability to
hold that physical
at the same time as we hold the mind and
this is sort of what rumi was saying
with
the relax into ever
expanding rings and in the sense you
have the physical
and then you have the mind which is a
little more subtle
and then you sort of get into that
eternal
style of awareness or consciousness that
you recognize
and then you relax even one more layer
beyond that and in a sense
reject that last thorn of even the
observer or the witness
into what is the ineffable absolute and
there are all these different ways to
describe this but the general idea is
that if you can hold all of that
simultaneously and recognize
that each one of these 8 billion units
on this creation design are undergoing a
different
unique process of their
unit being on a spectrum of what we just
described as those layers
that is what what that al-uujud means
regarding the unity of all finding
the unity of all of these individual
agents
and their processes that they're
undergoing across all of these layers
and so it's not ever an either this
or that but it's always this and that
it's the yin and the yang that are in
one
tijutu that are a non-dual
with the dualistic concession as one
in the collective and the individual and
all of these breakdowns it's the
simultaneity that we've recognized
is so key yeah i would call that
integral um an integral is another
beautiful way to put it yes
yeah that you don't have to
yeah you don't have to either or it you
don't have to exclude
any stage or aspect of
your being that we where we're both
and um uh
i guess for me one of the things that's
changed in the last few years
is that i no longer
really think that
the states of awareness that i
access and meditation or
um or that we read descriptions of
uh are necessarily
uh
descriptions of ultimate reality
or something like that that that they
are
extremely interesting compelling
and potentially very useful
and valuable on their own terms
states and that
that's it and i think that might that's
a difference i think
in the way that you and i language and i
think think about these experiences at
least that's my impression
um i don't unless you're speaking
poetically metaphorically
i don't really think i don't think
there's
evidence that meditative
states um uh
give access to truths about the ultimate
nature of reality
necessarily they may give access to
to truths about how my own mind works
and how i feel about things and how my
perceptual apparatus
does its thing um but beyond that i
think
the claims are interesting a bit
overstated and that that
matters because
the one of the upshots of that
and this is really under the uh my
influenced heavily by julian walker's
thinking in this way
um abuses occur when teachers
feel empowered to make grand grand
claims about the nature of reality
because they're good at meditating
that can get into tricky territory
there's a lot of perverse incentives
there for sure
and that's why and that's why you can
never
shed fully the
unit because the conditioning of it
is how it the it conditions its
understanding of what is
absolute or god realization etc
and so this this the beautiful
similarity
i feel is just in slightly different
phrasings which goes something like this
that there is
no way for us
within maya or the illusion or the dream
or this physicalism this creation design
for us to know ultimate reality
it's just ineffable and that's sort of
the non-dual
and then the dualistic concession goes
something like
well actually there are people at the
mountaintop
and the less perverse incentives that
they have at the mountaintop the better
and that they act as a vortex in a sense
because they've done the work across
these
paths which enables them
to have as close as
possible to the ineffable anchored
within their essence
which then acts as that vortex of
pulling other people up
towards that imperturbable peace and
causeless joy that just butterfly
effects out
so that so that sounds similar yeah yeah
i don't think we're far off at all
um the you
you can ha have all kinds of
really really profound and
useful experiences like like cessation
let's say
in the buddhist in the theravada
tradition the
the sudden blinking out of
consciousness itself and then when when
you come back online so to speak your
experiencing things as if in a
completely
pure state of compassion and in the
moment
consciousness of what's arising
beautifully
which is a beautiful and really
energizing experience
and you don't have to
unpack that in a way that makes claims
about objective
external reality based on that like
let's
let's look to science for those
to validate those kinds of claims so
that that's the
distinction that i make and the
scientific
analysis of these
more spiritual and
intuitive in a sense leaps
of faith that happen
are both quite difficult right now
for science yet it is creeping
more and more into its domain which is
exciting
yeah yeah i agree yeah yeah a lot of
sciency people
are and not all of them but but
but some science-minded rational type
people
tend to be closed off to
um this whole domain of of you know
trying to access altered states interior
states of you know insider reverie or
bliss or whatever um because
well it just sounds like so much woo
right and that's why i think that it's
up to people like us
to start to think really precisely about
these things
and language it carefully yeah so that
we don't scare away the science people
and this we need them correct and this
is where i would say things like
where you take things like
the physicalism
story of the big bang
and where you add a pair
of eyeballs as consciousness or
awareness to that point
and then you click the play button
and then scrub the timeline like in a
video
all the way to 13.8 billion years later
aka right now and then you just
see that there's one consciousness or
one
awareness or one observer or one witness
which is in fact
god that has been in many ways
misinterpreted
dogmatically and fundamentally which is
why rational people
sometimes get triggered but then that
one observer witness
god consciousness awareness is
what is shared amongst all eight billion
of
us that's the pupil that's the pupil
whereas the iris is the unique
expression of that and so now you get
more and more scientific people that go
hmm
cool could be something interesting to
explore and understand better
and then you just give them even more of
these
kind of most
fundamental
and simple
explain like i'm five analogies
where we take something like
the
so we're gonna have we're gonna have
we're gonna have blake over here on this
side
and we're gonna have atlas over here on
this side
so blake and atlas are
from the big bang right even from a
scientific perspective
this is the blank awareness or the blank
consciousness and you can tell that it's
the same
it's the blank awareness or the blank
consciousness
and then guess what happens the unique
coloration so blake
gets this walter russell art
and i get the walter russell poets code
of ethics
so you get this visual artistic one
and i get this words one
and so when you look back again
it is the blank awareness or the blank
consciousness that is being eternally
colored
by the experience of the unique iris
so the pupil being colored by the unique
iris eternally and so there's these very
explained like m5 child like ways to get
even that's why sir roger penrose who
won the nobel prize in physics in 2020
has a cyclic
cosmology because there's just
there's nothing else that even
scientifically makes sense
to just say that ah yeah this is it big
bang 13.8 billion years later this
physicalism that's all that is
done nothing before nothing after done
that's what this
is it makes no sense recursion is
everywhere aka the procedure calls upon
itself
if you look at a oak tree that drops an
acorn that then makes more oak trees
or if you look at humans that go
from two
into a union where the sperm and the egg
make another child that's birthed into
the world
that then goes on to make a union with
another
that then bursts a child into the world
that's recursion
so why would realities not be cyclic
themselves it's absurd to think
that that this is
that god or awareness or consciousness
is finite but in the sense of
simultaneity we recognize
that this expression is unique
to the extent at which the
expression itself
is experienced via the dream
which is a quote finite
black and atlas and yet it is also
simultaneously the eternity
and so that's the simultaneous what do
you think of these
sort of explain like i'm five analogies
how do these sort of resonate with you
well i like it no i mean i
it definitely helped me to understand
what you're saying cool
cool from what i understand what you're
describing is
i think what it's called if you wanted
to
um label it in terms of its
philosophical
school is pan psychism i think that's
what they're calling it
uh that is different from emergentism
that the idea of emergenism claims that
consciousness
must have emerged as a function or
an effect of certain neurobiological
processes
in physical brains and nervous systems
that it must have
somehow emerged into existence
with new and emergent properties um
called consciousness as but but as
as an effect of physical processes
whereas pan psychism claims which i
think is what you're doing
that that
consciousness was at least in some way
here all along that they call it
prehension
they posit um a kind of proto
or very primitive consciousness they
call it prehension
they say it's a kind of um
yearning or aspiration to become
which is loaded and baked into the
very primordial
fabric of existence itself
and these two camps will go at it
um and look i you know i have been
um whereas simultaneity would say
potentially something like
all of it is integral whereas
when you dream at night when you're
sleeping
when you simulate that dreamed reality
and you immerse yourself in the first
person could you
have that dreamed reality without a
first person observer or a witness
could you have that would it be possible
to have that without a dream
if you couldn't immerse yourself in it
in first person
no you need you need to some kind of
subjectivity something that it's like to
be you in order to have any experience
at all
and then the next question would be is
there any separation between the
observer and its quote dreamed
environment
or is it all one dreamed simulation
well i think for me what comes up there
is that
there are states in which
the environment and the observer
merge or like i was saying the the
seeming
separation between them collapses
and there is a kind of unitive
experience of
feeling deeply connected to your
surroundings and that can be
really meaningful
[Music]
but even as that's happening in the
moment that that's happening
if you were observing a meditator from
the outside who was in that state
i mean obviously there would still be a
boundary
of a sort between him or her
and the external environment namely
their skin right so
sure we have to be careful about
simultaneity how we're using these
yeah yeah sort of poetically evocative
yes yes simultaneity is key here or
integrality
so even though the
in the most non-dual sense the dreamed
environment
in the dream is not separate from the
observer
at the same time as in the dualistic
concession you can say that you as the
first person observer
in the dreamed environment are separate
from the other
dreamed characters in that environment
that you're engaging with or interacting
with
or the trees or the houses or the
objects within it as well
and then that same as above so below
applies here
as well we can think about this in many
ways
like god's dream and one of
many of the creation design dreams
and that as much as we want to
both say that there is that
pupil of that non-dual as well as the
iris of the unique individuation
is the simultaneity the integrality
in the sense of emergentism and
physicalism
or free will and determinism
or as we were saying earlier this
conservatism versus liberalism or the
collectivism versus the individuality
it's like how many more of these
dualistic juxtapositions do we have to
go through which we've already went
through
ever since thousands of years ago when
we created even
across the planet the taijitsu the yin
yang
across different traditions they put the
monism
and the dualism in one symbol because
they just wanted to make it that clear
yeah that's the the thai key the yin
yang symbol
yeah yeah an amazing symbol yeah no i
think
yeah there's wow there's a lot there
[Music]
um
i mean i was uh
i think by temperament i am
the most romantic the most sort of
mystical mystical that you can get
um and i've actually had to be dragged
kicking and screaming
by a couple of key figures
teachers into
what i think of as a more rational
worldview i didn't want to think this
way
because i worried that it would
spoil the mystery the the beauty the aw
the um and i
i have actually found that it didn't um
i i really do think differently than i
used to
but i think that ultimately what i
saw and what was so actually
heart-wrenching about that shift
and i guess i'm i'm riffing on what you
just said but taking it
down to the personal uh or you know
yeah how does the the philosophical
stuff
relate to the personal
this this shift happened for me when
i noticed in meditation and in therapy
and in conversation
so all these processes of self
reflection and inquiry and study
that i was clinging to certain ideas
that sounded really exciting and really
intoxicating totally because
i needed them because without them i
felt
much more vulnerable and exposed
to the unresolved wounds of my past
and that in some sense they were a
refuge
from suffering
because they were really sweet really
beautiful
hangouts yeah and then when i saw that
and i saw it just starkly i was like wow
that is what you are doing you don't
believe these things because it makes
sense
or because you've seen evidence you
believe it because you
want to because it feels good yeah then
everything collapsed and it was like a
you know it was like like they talk
about you know like a in the bible like
a crisis of faith
you know and i felt like i was losing
my my treasures
or you know like my my compass
and actually on the other side of it
i just feel freer and the world is
just as fun just as interesting
um but you know you talk about
physicalism
and um
uh what is it that you call it uh
like the more spiritual angle on reality
versus physicalism
we can just say consciousness and
physicalism
or spirituality and science which are
again just a dualistic concession for
what is non-dual which is not two so
it's a synthesis of both of those
what you just said a moment ago was
really important
and the way that i would potentially hit
a ball back to that
would be something along the lines of
both the first realization
of what could be considered an ultimate
truth within that integral
as we've been talking about would be
that the ineffable
cannot have descriptors or attributes
attached to it
so first of all there's absolutely
nothing to say
that's it done there's nothing to say
first point
second point is that literally the
coolest thing to do
is to try and use symbols to describe
the absolute
there's nothing more fun to do for me
this unique expression
is finding that that is the coolest
thing to do now there are many other
unique expressions that are choosing to
pursue maya
the intoxications of the illusion which
is totally cool
that's the unique expression of it so
that's the integral perspective
yet at the same time the dualistic
concession is for those that want to
recognize the diamond necklace around
their neck to recognize god realization
that there is this path up this mountain
the pathless path
and that the
tennis if you will
that is closest to the ineffable so the
exchange of symbols that are
as close as you can again the saguna
brahman
so we're adding attributes to what is
the nirguna brahmin or the
attributeless absolute
and so we're adding
symbols as much as we can to get closest
and closest
to what that is and it's super fun to do
and we recognize that we
are doing that we recognize we were
doing that and then fred davis was
recently on our show who's a great
non-dual teacher and he says that
be very vigilant to never make it a
personality teaching
and that's sort of what you were
targeting a moment ago
you don't want to ever make it a
personality teaching when you say things
like
the essence of the absolute is yes
attributeless
and then the next expression of it
is the creativity or the anarchy
or the leela the divine play right
so as close as we can say that yeah
that's pretty close
but we're not making it a personality
teaching where it's like okay
now we're gonna charge you a thousand
dollars to attend this retreat
and we're gonna tell you the ultimate
truth yay
yeah no no that we need to grow out of
that exactly we really do
because it's the problem with it is that
when people set themselves up like that
as some kind of um
infallible spiritual authority
there is a market for it precisely
because
there are a lot of wounded vulnerable
impressionable gullible people out there
who in need a new parent
who seems they need they need some
parental authority figure to project
their idealization needs on
onto that they didn't get completed in
childhood so that they can
live out this kind of old narcissistic
need for validation and to be seen
and to be uh told what to do
this is we've seen this over and over in
the west with with
um actually what we were just talking
about a moment ago which is
people like jordan peterson in a sense
you can even
in a sense say that in the dualistic
concession
that there are plenty of people that are
looking for
a parental style figure to pass along
some of these traditional
timeless wisdoms that then enable them
to more
optimally recognize their god
realization as well as the unique
expression
so there is in the duelist the
concession some sort of a market
in a sense for awakening but to not be
perverse about it that's the key whether
it be tony robbins or jordan peterson or
gary vaynerchuk or
any of the teachings of rupert spyra or
bentino massaro
or any of the fred davises or the ones
that are alive
today that are doing the teachings to
just not be perverse about it
which when you get to those states
usually you are not perverse about it
well like i mean i think shinzon is
pretty responsible
shinsen's pretty responsible shinzen
young in the way that he
talks about things i i remember
i mean two things that he has said uh
that really moved me um
one time we were i went to a talk of his
with
george and george is like a you know
flat out buddhist atheist rational
period and at that time i was more of
like a
new age believer so we go to this
shinzon talk the great meditation
teacher and
i'm sitting there with george and
shinzen keeps using this word source
like with a capital s
then you return to your spiritual source
this is the path the direct path to
source
and i was like well what what does he
mean by that
is he talking about uh you know an
objectively
ontologically real
like divine source like a god or
or is he just using this word poetically
metaphorically to allude to
an experience that you have in
meditation
so i raised my hand and i asked him that
and i really wanted him to say the
former i really wanted him to
say oh no you are contacting
source a true and you know
real as anything else spiritual source
that's
you know i wanted him to validate
essentially
what i now think of as my fundamentalist
uh
belief structure and he said
he disappointed me profoundly he said oh
no definitely the latter i'm just
speaking poetically
i would never waste my time or yours
speculating about objective reality or
anything like that this is not my
area of expertise uh so that was like
devastating and it took me several years
to sort it out
and liberating yes no it was it is
ultimately
it's liberating because then you don't
have to put
too much on your experiences they're
just
experiences they mean what they mean on
their own terms
and they're incredibly rich incredibly
significant
but you don't have to guild the lily as
my friend
julian walker says and then the other
story
it's really briefly shinzon said that
bears on what we're talking about he
said
there have been a lot of
million dollar ideas in the history of
our species
there's even been a few billion dollar
ideas but there's only
one trillion dollar idea
and it is the marriage of science and
spirituality
and that's exactly what we've been
promulgating on the show over the last
year is that exact thing
which is the synthesis of science and
spirituality they are the
they are the two
if you in the dualistic concession you
separate them into two separate things
and then you say that they are the two
greatest driving forces of where we're
at today
boom done got it and then the synthesis
of the two where you drain the dirty
bath water from each because i do agree
with you there's dirty bath bathwater
and dogmas and fundamentalism
in spirituality and when someone is
trying to peddle you
uh snake oil that science can come in
and say
uh that's not what it actually does
whereas
on the scientific side the perverse
incentives and the dirty bath water
are like what we saw with the
dropping of the nuclear bombs onto
hiroshima nagasaki when you
you know when you wake up spiritually
you recognize
that our science should not be serving
the 13
000 nuclear bombs on the planet and bio
warfare and perverse
artificial general intelligence
incentives
and mind control via neuralink and stuff
like that but when you wake up
spiritually
it enables you morally to be able to
architect the science technology and
engineering
with a high degree of ethics and
morality the
highest degree of those which then
prevent
perverse incentives from formulating
downstream so i really appreciate that
story from shenzhen young because
i truly agree that the trillion dollar
idea
is that and also within the first story
that's why we use this sort of flat
mountain idea because it pretty much
it pretty much sums it up in a way that
sort of resonates
in in the way that most people can
generally understand it so
we have in this in this flat mountain
we have both the flatness
which is the non-duality which is what
you expressed
with there is no ultimate
it's ineffable done it just is
that's it okay cool then you have the
mountain the mountain is the dualistic
concession so it's to say that
if you are baked into maya
intoxicated by it and you have the
seeking impulse like a gps
that's going like like a call back in a
sense like in the parable of the
prodigal son
to be called back to your source or to
be called back to consciousness or
awareness pure
by itself without the coloration of
experience of maya
to that god realization to that
ineffable that absolute
then you have this mountain with all of
these different
paths and these different paths are like
the planetary mystic traditions
they are like the books and the
aphorisms and the meditation retreats
and all of these types of things that
exist
in order for you to undergo said process
and so that's why
that non-dual plus dualistic concession
simultaneously or integrally it sort of
solves
the
a majority of the both
bickerings and discrepancies
and even the greatest games of tennis
that are played at
the closest levels to the ineffable and
so
that's why you know one of our main
roles on
not only on the program but in general
with this unique expression
of what this unit is is to visualize
these things and to try and
not say that this is the ultimate truth
er it's so dumb it's dumb but to say
that
hey hopefully this one is
fairly close to what you feel is that
ineffable and maybe it can help bring
you value
maybe it can help bring you uh an
eradication of some of the suffering
that you're experiencing towards a state
of more well-being
in that dualistic mountain yeah yeah
that
here is a way of talking about
subjective experience here is a way a
map
of the territory
of the interior that's yeah that's a
that way of talking doesn't present any
problems
it's it's it's helpful without
being um so literal
that it risks mistaking mistaking the
map
for the map of the interior for a
description
of you know reality writ large
that that's where people get into
trouble with
you know and fall into literalist
fundamentalist exactly thinking which
leads to
you know sectarianism yeah exactly
exactly
yeah the wars where you have
you know 100 plus million people that
die in the 20th century
it really stems from the
inability to be integral
and so the more integral and the more
simultaneity
that we have
the less violence the
that's why ramana maharshi said that the
greatest service that you can render the
world is to god realize
ultimately what that does is it leads to
effortless action in your daily
activities like lao tzu said
where everything you do downstream is
from the absolute highest
morality because you recognize that
blake is
the same being that i am well
again when the simultaneity you would
recognize them as individual units and
as well as the same being at the same
time
and so it's all about that
yet it's also about somebody that is in
the intoxication of maya that is
pursuing a lamborghini right now
it's also that and that's the richness
of what the
dream is yeah and so there's no dogma
there's no fundamentalism and that's why
you have these
you have these other uh as we've sort of
you know you you really you really liked
this one
yeah and it is
very much resonant with what you have
previously
explored yourself as well so you have in
the bottom right corner the spiral
dynamics which we're very familiar with
which is a really strong
map claire graves chris cowan don beck
yeah i got into it through ken wilbur
exactly can we
use him of bastardizing it but no that's
where i first heard of it
exactly not at all that's where i first
heard of it too and then it led me to
claire graves and don beck and chris
cowan and i was
looking them up in more detail and
they're brilliant as well it's really
cool
it's so good and so then that's in the
bottom right corner as a great map and
then the bottom left corner is a great
map
of the levels of consciousness by david
hawkins who does a great job at it
and in the top right is the law of one
and that's an incredible phd in
metaphysics in its own sense as well
but the idea is that in the top left is
just this fun
infinite absolutely beautiful image and
so
the idea is that these are maps
what we showed you here is a map what we
showed you with flat mountain is a map
but we are not saying it is the
ineffable territory
that's it yeah i think that's a really
important distinction
to make and to make it explicit to
people um
over and over because you know
like there's two kinds of people in the
world people who understand
metaphors and people who don't and
there's a lot of the second kind
you know that when you start talking in
a certain way
they assume that you mean this literally
when you say
i i blinked out of existence during my
meditation
they think that you mean that you
literally
disappeared but of course that's not
what you're saying at all you just
you had a discontinuity in your
awareness you suddenly
had an experience of
that of disappearing but you know that
you were sitting there the whole time
so that's just an example but um
yep yeah and then you know with this
stage of development stuff
i guess for me the real
what i've let go of is the idea
of a conscious or
proto-conscious telos you know that word
yeah teleology totally
that is animating the
the movement from stage to stage i think
these these maps of stages of
development
are descriptions of what
we see when we look at what's what has
occurred
in in the development of an individual
human being or
in the development of a culture this is
the track that
it seems to follow yeah but that doesn't
imply
that there is some necessarily
some
conscious uh
transcendent aspect that is
guiding that evolution toward
something totally it's just what is
happening that's exactly and that's why
the term metaphysical anarchy has been
one that's really resonated
in that in that regard i like that i
like that see
i think that's the track i'm on i might
be a metaphysical anarchist
yeah because ultimately that's what the
expression at the most non-dual
layer is it's a metaphysical anarchy and
then in the dualistic concession
you have all of these ideas of these
levels of consciousness and these
densities of
of the maps all of these maps the spiral
dynamics all this type of stuff
or as you were indicating a moment ago
there's the people that say that ah
it's lila it's the divine play or the
cosmic play
or it's the source is creative or the
ineffable is creative or the ineffable
is already perfect or already whole or
any descriptor basically yeah even
anarchy in itself
is still a descriptor totally but
totally it's the one that
is in a sense the
least of a descriptor in a sense it's
the most
attributeless descriptor it's also a
metaphor
but it's it's maybe a little adhering a
little closer
more closely to what's actually going on
although dance of leela is a beautiful
image for understanding certain aspects
of reality
if it's understood as poetry right yeah
i mean it's poetry it's not there's no
literal
i mean it's yeah correct correct this
this would be another sort of synthesis
of what we just
uh talked about a moment ago which is
that
in this most
highest sense we can think about
these maps like we were just showing you
a moment ago
as the best possible games of tennis
that we're playing around the ineffable
absolute
but we recognize that they're just maps
the highest maps
but it's again it's not it is
not the ineffable territory itself
even the word anarchy itself is
the potentially closest attribute we can
ascribe to but it is still
not the ineffable territory and by doing
these top two things
what happens is you recognize that there
is
the most optimal is when there's no
dogma there's no perverse incentives
around these so that's just what sort of
came up as an exegesis
for me i was drawing out drawing out the
salience of our conversation
no that's good i'm on board with that
cool cool yeah that's ultimately what we
do on the program is we
aim to we aim to
um to get as
as uh strong of an exegesis
out we try and draw out as much of the
salience
in these highest games of tennis around
the ineffable and we try and visualize
them
which is why we have these great
maps of these seven densities these
levels of consciousness spiral dynamics
they're the maps that are for now
in a sense closest but we recognize they
are not the ineffable absolute we
recognize we are not
going to be charging people a thousand
dollars to attend retreats
for people to come and to learn about
these
most direct transmissions that's why the
theravada buddhism
meditation retreats that's why they
via the most direct conservative
teachings of buddha
and thank goodness for sm and for
the entirety of the organization at
large
for preserving it but that's why they
are free
the 10-day meditation retreats are free
they're donation-based afterwards if you
had a profound
experience you can make a donation right
and
that's where you retain in a sense in
many ways
the core ethos of what is
non-duality or the ineffable because the
moment that you begin in a sense
charging for it
and this is what i've had a struggle
with with our channel as well
is because around two years ago we
launched the patreon and the
cryptocurrency donations and the paypal
donations and stuff like that
and even up until just yesterday
we launched what is like the join button
at the bottom of the
youtube right underneath of the like
button where people can join into the
membership
program or the exclusive perks and stuff
and i've always had a struggle with this
because all of our content should be
absolutely free
always period that's the ethic that
we've had since 2017 since
inception yet at the same time we're
recognizing that
it's beautiful for people that want
additional value
if they want a private community group
chat or if they want exclusive videos or
if they want
the their name etched into the bio of
the video
and whatnot or if they want the
to be able to ask our guests the
interviewees
questions that to provide these things
of value
money can be seen as just energy as in
it is the energetic transmission
from the guests from the viewers to the
show
that then makes it so that we can funnel
more energy
money into the literal development of
the further content so when you give a
donation at the end of the theravada
buddhism meditation tree
all you're doing is you're funneling the
further purchase of the food
and the upgrade of the the
not only the dhamma hall but also
potentially the pagoda
which is fantastic if you have those
individual cell units and stuff
the food that they serve for free as
well so this is the type of stuff to
think about is
the money acts as a mechanism to
energetically enhance
the
the creative expression yeah yeah
totally to
to facilitate the dharma
and the the the sharing of these
important things i think
i guess the only thing i would add to
that is that i think
for spiritual types and artistic types
there does
seem to be a tendency
to have a kind of
bias against
capitalism commerce market economies
uh which i i
you know i was you know leave it up to
the listener to decide or
whatever you think but the more i've
learned about
history and economics which is
just enough to know that i hardly know
anything
the more i think that there is dignity
in
market transactions and that
we don't necessarily have to
think of them as demeaning or degrading
to
what we're offering that actually
totally this this
this in some sense of of course
capitalist
um relationships can become corrupted
and and uh exaggerated
and left unregulated people can get hurt
and all these kinds of and exploited
yes but fundamentally i think there's a
pretty good
idea there that that i have something of
value to offer
totally and you might be willing to
support me
exactly with this construct we've
invented that's
real in our minds called money that's it
um
that's basically a a good
spot on exchange yeah ultimately it's
gonna be a synthesis
where we drain the dirty bath water from
both capitalism and socialism and we
uplift them both
and merge them together where you have
something like when you look at in 1906
we have the american antiquities act
and so you have teddy roosevelt and john
muir that go out to yosemite
and they're like dude this [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] beautiful
that we know that if we leave this
untouched and other sites like this
around the us
untouched that corporate entities are
going to come and chop down
all of these trees and mine all of this
rock and there's going to be no beauty
left
and so you make the american antiquities
act you make the national park system
right or if you want a modern example
you look at what happened with the
sackler family
and purdue and purdue pharma and the
opioid epidemic yeah what a
horrible thing and so that's another
perverse incentive that you can have in
the capitalistic structure
but what you do is over time with the
free market
with markets in general what you do over
time is you iron out the externalities
that create these perverse incentives
and you make them more and more in
service to the well-being and prosperity
of the entire
collective totally yeah and so it's not
without
without hopefully um heavy-handedly
inserting the state into the doings of
individual citizens so there's a really
complicated balance
to strike there yeah and that's what you
know that's what a lot of our politics
that's basically our whole political
system is about that it's that argument
in a sense it can be summed up as the
the liberals want in the united states
want
a more robust social fabric
and conservatives want a more robust
individual
in a sense and then there's of course
the libertarian perspective as well
so there's donald trump just wants a
more robust
donald trump and that's it there were
definitely some
fascinating um geopolitical dynamics
as well that emerged from the
ability to see in a sense
what is the dirty bathwater of the usa
and china and what is the uplifting of
the good codes from each of them
i went to china in 2019 for partnership
interviews for three weeks
and i found the energy of the culture to
be
so incredible and
there is basically a massive propaganda
machine that exists
in china about the us and a propaganda
machine in the u.s that exists about
china
and also in russia that exists about the
u.s and u.s exists about russia and
saudi arabia etc
but what happens when you go to jeddah
or to riyadh or to moscow or saint
petersburg or beijing or shanghai
or when they come to new york city or
los angeles or san francisco
what happens is a massive melting
of xenophobia totally that's what
happens yeah
sweet people it's like we may have
criticisms of their government but when
you meet a chinese person or a russian
person it's not like
you know they're just people
they're just like us
yeah that i mean that's you know like a
very
very elementary failure if people can't
distinguish between
um you know uh totalitarian government
and the citizenry
of the people who live in that country i
mean it's like
but but you do see that happening you
know like and that's the dirty
water failures regarding the way they
handled the virus
and so certain kind of person in america
hates chinese people i mean it makes
about as much sense
and it makes no sense at all it's like
all of these
on a geopolitical stage all these
figures of the united nations are going
to have some dirty bath water they're
going to have some good ideas
but to be able to basically have the
sorting algorithm
functioning all the time and that's what
spirituality means in many ways is the
word discernment
yeah do you have discernment that's what
netty netty means
it's not this it's not that it's not
this cloud that comes
and tells me you are this emotion of
anger
you are that but to have the discernment
to say no i'm
not that what i am is the sky where the
cloud is happening yeah
yeah resolution power discrimination
power
yes exactly and that's that's what we
did in wants
nuance exactly yeah in 2018 i changed my
middle name to nuance
did you really yeah i did i changed my
middle name to nuance it was
alan nuan saki on from 2018 to 2020
and then at the end of 2020 i dropped
allen
nuance and sakyon changed just to atlas
and then i went through my satori last
month
and then that dropped even atlas
and now you're just now it just is
it's hilarious nice but if you say if
blake's like
hey atlas would you mind grabbing me a
drink of water you know i'm not going to
be like
atlas doesn't exist you know so you
function through the simultaneously
you're making the what do you call it
the
the dual concession the duelist
consensus exactly we make that dual
concession
exactly and that's why there are these
crevices
that are really important to mention
because we
we almost in a sense we like we
completely forget
that there are these crevices as you go
up
towards in the dualistic concession in
the mountain you go up these paths
towards this absolute and what happens
is that you get to like the hikers on
mount everest where there
are these areas of fresh snowfall where
you can't actually see this 50-foot
crevice you fall in and you die
and what that means is if you're not
following like buddha said the middle
path or the middle way or like ramana
maharshi said sahaja samadhi
or like the tantric path where you're
basically
not weaving your enlightened
realizations into the social fabric
itself into your daily activities great
fantastic i love that yeah i mean it's
like you hear these stories of the
great enlightened masters in india and
then
that that they're in such a state of
unity of bliss all the time they can't
do anything
they just sit there and they have these
sort of disciples around them who bring
them
food and sort of like put it in their
mouth and then every once in a while
they get it together to like give a talk
yeah and it's like a great talk but
that's not what i want
for my life i want to be flexible i want
to have
a range of expression available to me
including like you say
showing up in the world that's so
essential and i think
we're probably moving toward a close
here but this is exactly yeah um
including your acting and producing
right your artistic expression
because i think a lot of the people that
are drawn to spirituality
do so because
they've been wounded and what they want
and this is certainly the case for me in
my story is a space
that tells them you don't have to engage
with the world
because one of the things that happens
that breaks when people get really hurt
is their capacity to connect to connect
in relationship and to connect with the
world
and so if someone says well no you don't
have to do that all you have to do is
sit in this tastefully lit
room with these beautiful buddha statues
and listen to me
talk you will stunt their gr
their development as a human being those
you know they have to face
those wounds and move through them if
they're going to
be fully integrated and so
that's just another way of explaining
why i think it's so important that
meditation teachers don't pretend
that meditation on the cushion
or in the meditation hall is the whole
meal
uh there's more to do there's you know
the effortless action once one god
realizes
the way that naturally channels through
the unit into
the expression of that unit in the
social fabric
in the butterfly effect of the
imperturbable peace and causeless joy
into the family the community the world
at large
and also all of the entrepreneurship and
creativity with the planetary
architectures that maximize
well-being prosperity abundance
flourishing
that is it that is it yeah
good good what a gorgeous convo
on all fronts thank you blake this has
been our honor our pleasure
we've loved having your flower blossom
on the program the aroma has been
delicious
appreciate it appreciate you having me
it's a great conversation
so awesome and i'm really grateful you
shared so much of your story with us
grateful to michael holt for making the
introduction it was so spot-on
yeah oh good good it was so spot-on that
was so good
and i love the way we hit the tennis
ball back around as close as we could to
that absolute
is that ineffable and and we know that
it's as close as we can and we know that
it's not a dogmatic
ultimate yeah and i think by not
by not having to be perfectly
um in alignment and an agreement all the
time
we were able to actually get to zero in
on shared truths
uh even more deeply exactly
one of the key things that's come up
from the guests that come on the show is
that
by having not only a polymathic
interlocutor
and one with high emotional intelligence
and spiritual intelligence but one
that's also has
uh an amount of disagreeableness on the
big five
in the personality traits is just enough
exactly yeah
i think it was gertrude stein who said
too much agreement
spoils a chat there you go
that's a good one yeah it's a really
good thing super succinct
yeah i'm excited to re-listen and take
some notes because there were a bunch of
good the shinzon young quote about the
trillion dollar idea
these are concepts that i'm going to be
adding into a lot of the images and
visualizations
right especially the gertrude stein yeah
yeah too much agreement can spoil
the chat spoils and i'm i may be
misattributing that quote it may not be
gertrude stein
it may be hemingway i don't know it
might be hemingway that's cool well
we'll we'll uh we'll identify
yeah blake super grateful thank you for
coming on the show welcome thank you
thank you and thanks everybody for
tuning in we love you so much
thank you thank you for tuning in thank
you we would love to hear
your thoughts about the show in the
comments below let us know how you feel
we'd love to hear from you
about all of the cool topics that we've
been discussing
and also if it brought you value like
the video
subscribe if you haven't share it with
other people that you feel like this
would resonate with
and also check out
the links in the bio below as well
so we have for you the
we have the venice yogi.com link for you
to
support blake we have his imdb profile
we have his instagram go and follow him
there and you can check out his
wikipedia as well
where his filmography is as well as
the television yeah i'm gonna be
launching a um
a crowd sourcing thing in the next
few weeks to produce my my play it's
just going to be like a
play filmed in one location like a movie
um so if you follow me on instagram then
i will conscript you in that cause
yeah it's going to be a really amazing
um
creative exactly work that we're we're
trying to
like we've been talking about unfold
into the world something that's
a lot we've put a lot into this play and
it's exciting
yeah great arsonist of venice yeah the
arsonist of venison
so there will be a crowd funding
campaign
with kind of like a a video promotion
for it
yeah we've shot a scene already and
we're to put that on the website
and exciting yeah that's that's the way
to do it and to gain that support again
that energy that fuel
for it yeah totally yeah that's all
folks thank you so much we love you
infinite love thank you much love peace